what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
so writer Shaun Murphy is probably gonna
go down as one of the greatest Batman
writers of all time and it's stuff like
this that makes you want to see like
things beyond this yes why I love those
you guys who don't know
DC's playing it really really smart when
it comes to DC rebirth Marvel kind of
has the stance of like is it a story
somebody can write then like give it an
ongoing series that's kind of Marvel
stance that's one of reasons why they're
publishing like 60 comic books but DC
has this I had this idea of just doing
like miniseries and that's it DC is
running like like five or six Batman
miniseries at the moment like Sims the
father and all these really really cool
stories when it came to like Nightwing
the new order it was just like a
different take on the Nightwing
character or things had basically gone
awry and that's what I love about this
is because what it does is it gives you
this amazing story at least you know the
white knight does it give you this
amazing story and then it kind of
answers the question so what if we
expanded this out to like the bigger DC
Universe so like Shazam and the Justice
League and like all these different
characters and all these different
things what would it look like and like
that's the cool thing about this cuz
like it makes you want to see more but
in the last video we talked about how
Batman had basically like gone crazy
tracked the Joker down forced a handful
of pills down his throat and ultimately
the Joker became sane as a result of
those pills and the result was the Joker
while he wasn't heard by the police
basically came up with this I at this
argument that like the cops have
systematically helped the Batman become
a vigilante that they're part of a
bigger problem now what that problem was
was something that the comic ended on it
was basically the Joker is Jack Napier
back to his normal self essentially
saying I will bring light to this
problem I will show the city of Gotham
what you really are and so that was the
question that I saw in the comments from
a lot of different people
if the Joker has had this life of just
killing arbitrarily and robbing folks
and doing all kinds of crazy things even
if he was on trial he would just get a
life sentence and that's it but this is
the beauty of the judicial system is
that at the end of the day it's not left
to a judge it's not left to like a cop
it's left to a jury
all the Joker has to do this convince a
jury and the opinions and the wants and
desires of the cops and the and the
lawyers and Neil Batman and the judge
they're all irrelevant and really like
Jack Napier does this in the smartest
way possible if you want to win anything
you have to win the people for the most
part the people are the ones who decide
what happens in a court of law it's no
different Jack Napier basically sits
down and says this is my city I came
here as an immigrant
like I came here from from a small rural
farm wanting to make a better life for
myself and when I got here I realized
that life was hard and life was rough
and like anybody who made bad decisions
I turned to a life of crime and and I
screwed up
once I was busted and I was sentenced to
10 years what I began to realize was
that crime is a product of the police in
Gotham because what the cops were doing
is they were basically using existing
criminals and turning them into like
super villains and then using them as a
means to keep crime going and it's the
greatest idea of a conspiracy because if
there's any one thing that people love
it's believing that like there's some
great you know some hidden hand out
there controlling everything behind the
scenes even if there's nook but in times
of desperation people will believe what
they want to believe and they'll simply
ignore facts if there are any at all and
so the result is that he basically sits
down and he says look at the city of
Gotham for what it is like look around
you and look at what it is what you see
are the wealthy prospering you see the
poor struggling and you see Batman
fighting the poor it's kind of Jack
maybe you're twisting up the facts to a
degree but it's also like providing a
pretty interesting image the Batman is
not a vigilante trying to keep Gotham
safe that Batman's not there to like
protect the people Batman's there to
protect the wealthy from the people and
it's so cool because it's like what
better way to turn the entire city of
Gotham on Batman than to basically say
like he's not here to protect you he's
here to protect the wealthy and the
powerful from you it's the Joker in a
lot of ways inciting revolution in the
city of Gotham it's so cool now the
other half of this is like how he feeds
on words for example there's a part of
Gotham City called back port which is
really where like a lot of minorities
live specifically african-americans but
the popular phrase to use is black port
and that's why this is cool because it's
turning all these things on the city of
Gotham itself it's criticizing the press
who are complicit in in the vigilantism
of Batman and in the actions of the
Gotham City Police Department it's the
Gotham City Police Department who's
complicit and basically the creation of
crime in Gotham and the profiteering of
crime is all these things that go on
it's so cool because he says look like
anytime anybody ever asked the question
well where's all this extra funding
going to you like what are you doing
with all this extra money where the
police department was using it to create
villains when people started asking too
many questions well oh no the Joker's
escaped we have to get the Joker guys
it's such a cool way to portray the city
of Gotham is just crooked and corrupt
and so what we do is we pick up with
Jack navier-- when he gets back to his
house and he's met with her
Clint right off the bat it's him trying
to relate to Harley Quinn and we would
kind of expect this but at the same time
we wouldn't Harley Quinn has always been
in love with like the Joker as a person
like how the Joker manifests himself and
how he treats her is just a byproduct of
the relationship but it was always like
her obsession with him she would follow
him to the edge of the earth and she
would do whatever it is that he wants
her to do because she believes that she
could psyche somehow fix him or turn him
around or get him to love her it's the
quintessential like good girl in love
with a bad boy
all the while never realizing that she's
just one of many women that bad guys
been with but where he starts to talk
about things like proposal and marriage
and be spills and so on and so forth she
immediately freaks out and starts
attacking him but while this is
happening were suddenly met with the
arrival of another Harley Quinn and I
was like what in the hell is going on
here as soon as I saw that I was like
Sean Murphy Sean Murphy man you you
genius but then as soon as I look at it
I'm like okay this looks like the
original Harley Quinn and that's when we
find out that it is that this is
actually the original Harley Quinn and
this this younger version of Harley
Quinn that exists out there at the
moment is not the actual Harley Quinn
and this is kind of funny because what
we find out is the original basically
left the Joker and a new one took her
place the Joker just never really
realized it he never knew what was going
on now this of course leads into like
the holes obvious question how could the
Joker not know that like Harley Quinn
took off and replaced her you know
replace yourself with somebody else and
it's kind of cool because Harley goes
through and tells her story and this is
what I liked here's what I love about
this so much is this like Shawn Murphy
grabbed all these different aspects and
all these different themes of Batman's
history with regards to different
characters and sort of rolled it all
together into a version that we're
familiar with but has changed just
enough to just kind of make it like a
fully unique and separate line of events
and much like the main the main DC
Universe when it comes to like Harley
and when it comes to it to this version
of her character is she fell in love
with Jack Napier as he was the Joker but
for her it really wasn't just like man
let's just let's just be crazy it wasn't
like she just snapped one day for her it
was an escape it was the idea that like
like her life was boring and it was
mundane rinse and repeat her life is is
by definition as she sees it completely
and totally mundane but the Joker
represented a change from that the Joker
was random he had no idea what was gonna
happen next and it gave Harley Quinn the
the belief that she was free from the
shackles of society I mean sure they
were vigilantes they were on the lam
but the fact remains that she could do
anything she wanted to there was no
limits to what she could do the world
was her oyster and she wasn't
constrained by like societal standards
and lost but as time began to progress
and when Batman first showed up she
began to notice that the Joker's
affection that his obsession switched
from Harley Quinn to Batman and that he
basically was in love with the idea of
Batman every thought that he ever had it
was all about Batman and Harley Quinn
began to fade further and further into
the background and because of that like
it gave her no desire to want to be with
him anymore but all this came to a head
when the Joker kidnapped Jason Todd now
again this is almost kind of like Shawn
Murphy's twist on the death in the
family storyline when like the Joker
basically killed Jason Todd like it's
kind of a kind of a twist on that idea
but were Harley Quinn's there she
basically kind of runs up it says look
you're going too far but notice this
this is not insane Harley Quinn this
isn't the kind of Harley Quinn that
we're used to where she just snaps one
day the Joker drove her insane
she's very sane she's completely and
totally rational she's like a regular
normal human being but the Joker
basically went too far this time it's
you can't just run around and kill
people not only that it's predicated on
the idea that like the Joker was jealous
of Jason Todd because Jason Todd was the
right-hand man of Batman how come I
can't be the right-hand man abandoned
how come I can't be that close to Batman
well then I'll just kill Jason Todd
because I'm so angry that he's in that
position not where the the implication
was that Joker had killed Jason although
were not explicitly told that was the
case Batman tries to kill the Joker and
Harley quit actually stops him and says
you can't kill him and so Joker
basically went back to Arkham Asylum and
that was really about it but this is
cool because what she basically says is
like sure I mean you know these these
pills kind of help you to maintain this
sort of luteum this lucidity but like
like Jack Napier recognizes the Joker's
still in there that's still very much a
part of who Jack Napier is but the
stance of Harley Quinn is you can be
fixed but you can be set back to normal
and so again that's why I love this so
much is because it's the Harley Quinn
concept as we know her without the
insanity that we're familiar with and so
ultimately Jack basically sits down with
her and says yeah I guess we can sort
this out I guess we can get this going
but the funny thing about this is that
this almost you know switching over to
Bruce Wayne when he meets up at a dinner
party it hits it this idea that Batman
didn't really know the impact of what it
was that he was doing he was blissfully
unaware of like the full totality of his
actions
and the reason why I say this is because
there's basically a guy here named
Pierce who's kind of a dick and
basically has been you know been
drinking alcohol the whole time and so
on and so forth but where you end up
having a Jack Napier and Harley Quinn
jump on TV and saying like we're taking
this settlement money and we're opening
the first library in backport and the
result is that Pierce basically starts
talking to Bruce Wayne about like the
nature of things what he says is that
inside of backport really inside of
Gotham II have were to call that impact
zones and what this means is that when
Batman shows up in an area and starts
fighting crime and of course damage is
done
it absolutely tanks the value of the
property well what wealthy people are
doing is they're going in and then
buying up all that property flipping it
and then selling it at a premium and so
they're basically making money off the
work of Batman and this like this pisses
off Bruce to the extreme but it's kind
of funny because it's like how could he
not know this how could a man who's one
of the who's like the richest person in
Gotham really have no idea that people
are doing this either it means that
Batman's incompetent as a superhero or
Batman's like genuinely just didn't know
but either way like it is it is really
cool because basically it means that
like the Joker was not lying
Batman was an enforcer for the rich and
the powerful in Gotham and so from here
you pick up with Jack Napier in Harley
Quinn basically meeting with a whole
bunch of different villains now the cool
thing about this meeting between the
Joker in these villains is there's a lot
of really really good Easter eggs in
here this is this is this is how you
know that like Shawn Murphy is like a
Batman fan because like there's these
little Easter eggs for example there's
one point where curly a Killer Croc says
it so it was a big rock now this comes
from Batman the Animated Series or
anybody who remembers Batman the
Animated Series back in the day and it
was an episode called almost got him
which is exactly why the what Jack
Napier says is like every time we talk
it turns into a game of almost scouted
that episode was was amazing it was cool
because it's basically got if I remember
correctly it's the Joker Killer Croc
poison ivy and two-faced I think maybe
even the penguin sitting around at a
poker game telling the story of how each
one of them almost got Batman and Killer
Croc is like yeah man like i lured
Batman into a sewer and they were like
yeah like and then and then what
happened he's like I threw a rock at him
and like they all start looking at him
kind of funny and he's like I mean it
was a big rock
you know but it is cool because what you
have is a joker basically say a really
jack maybe you're basically saying look
we should consolidate our efforts in
order to basically take the city of
Gotham back we have to work together if
we're gonna bring down Batman now
because of the fact that each one of
these villains is for the most part used
to
whirring on their own they basically
gave the most expected answer which is
not a chance we do our own thing like we
we we don't do that like we do our own
thing we commit our own act that's
basically what this is and so what we
end up finding out is that what the
Joker had done is actually taken I guess
what Jack Napier did I keep wanting to
say the Joker what Jack had done is he
had basically taken Clayface and he had
used one of the Mad Hatter's on
controlling cards along with the
controlling headband meaning he had
complete and total domination over
clayface's mind and then what he did is
he started to turn in Clayface into a
kind of like salt worse and more or less
and then began dispersing that among
like the various strengths that he had
inside this meeting and so what's been
going on is all the villains who were
here they've been drinking this offering
from the Joker all the while not
realizing they're actually ingesting the
ability for Joker to control them and
that's exactly what happens by this
extension Joker has single-handedly
taken over the entirety of the criminal
underworld
inside of Gotham City but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring that
video to an end if you are new here to
comics explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
you